MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This
is primarily a
question-and-answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions--
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
Well, welcome.
Hey.
So I'm Pete LePage and welcome
to the first of a series of
Chrome Mobile Hangouts.
With me here, we've got Boris.
I'll let you introduce
yourself.
BORIS SMUS: Hey, I'm Boris.
We're both from Chrome Developer
Relations, so mostly
working on mobile these days.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
So back at Google I/O, Chrome
for Android and Chrome for iOS
became available.
And we're really excited about
both of those, because it
really brings a great browser
to the mobile environments.
So today, we want to talk about
a couple of things that
we think is pretty
interesting.
Boris is going to start off
talking a little bit about
high DPI stuff.
So if you've been building web
applications or websites, and
you've used them on either one
of the new MacBooks that have
Retina display or on a
iPad3, you've seen
the high DPI stuff.
And the web looks a little bit
different if you're using one
of those devices than
something else.
And then I'm going to talk a
little bit about some of the
debugging tools that you can use
on Chrome for Android when
building these sites.
And then we'll take
some of your
questions through the moderator.
So Boris, I'll pass
it over to you.
You just had an article
about high DPI--
BORIS SMUS: We published
an article this
morning, "HTML5 Rocks".
Many thanks to Alex who
stayed up late in
Sydney to get that out.
So I just want to sort of
be more specific here.
The high DPI problem doesn't
just apply to iPads and
MacBook Pros with the
new Retina displays.
It's actually a general
problem on the web.
There's a lot of devices that
now have device pixel ratios
of greater than one.
I'll talk a little bit
more about what
that means in a second.
But it's an Android issue.
It's a Windows Phone 8 issue.
And it's an iPhone issue
and iPad issue.
So this high DPI question needs
to be solved generally
on the web and is being
worked on generally.
So there's this big thing about
Retina displays, but
that's just branding.
Right?
PETE LEPAGE: Ah, OK.
And it's also more than just,
OK, say, I've got this high
DPI image or a regular, but
there's also something about
choosing images based on screen
size too in there.
BORIS SMUS: Yeah.
It gets a little complicated,
actually.
Well, basically what you want to
do is you want to serve the
best quality image as
quickly as possible.
But the thing is what quality
means sort of depends.
Right?
You have like just pure
resolution, like crispness of
the pixels.
And then you have things like
for a small display, you want
to show up maybe a different
image than for large display.
Like say you have Obama speaking
at some conference or
something like that, maybe if
you have a large screen,
you'll show the pedestal,
you'll show
Obama's face as well.
But on a small screen, you
might just show his face,
because there's not
much real estate.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
I think in your article that
was just published--
and we can put the
link up for that.
But in that article, if you
scroll down, you actually have
a really good visual description
of that, where in
the foreground, you've got like
person and all of the
background image, like where
they're standing, where
they're talking.
But on a small screen
display, that person
just gets lost, right?
And you don't want to
show all of that.
BORIS SMUS: Right.
I actually don't have
that in the article.
But the article more focuses
on just the resolution.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, OK.
I might be thinking of a--
BORIS SMUS: That was
something else.
PETE LEPAGE: --different
article.
BORIS SMUS: Yeah.
Another article, I'm
sure, had that.
I know the exact image,
actually,
you're talking about.
But anyway, the way this whole
resolution aspect works, if
you ignore the art direction
of bits, it's sort of
complicated on the web, because
there's so many
different kinds of browsers
out there and so many
different devices.
Like on iOS, for example, you
just have 1x and 2x displays.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
So when you're talking
about 1x and 2x,
what does that mean?
Can you--
BORIS SMUS: Sure.
So basically a 1x image--
well, let's talk about
displays first.
A 1x display has
pixel density.
That's whatever the display's
pixel density is.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
So if I've got--
BORIS SMUS: For an iPhone, the
pixel density of the iPhone
3G, the pre-4 one, is
like 163, actually.
PETE LEPAGE: So that's
the pixel density.
So like in one inch, there's
about 163 pixels.
BORIS SMUS: Exactly 163.
Well, about on average.
So with a 2x display, there's
twice as many pixels in the
same space.
PETE LEPAGE: So roughly,
there's like 320
pixels in an inch.
BORIS SMUS: 326.
So that's the 2x display
of a iPhone.
Of course, the actual number of
pixels depends on what the
initial 1x was.
So like an iPad is slightly
less dense.
A MacBook Pro is even
But the 2x equivalents
are doubled.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
All right.
BORIS SMUS: So that's the
way that that works.
It makes it really simple
for Apple developers
to solve this problem.
Android also has a
similar concept.
But because of the variable
display densities,
there's no 2x notion.
So you sort of need to cover
the whole gamut of
possibilities.
PETE LEPAGE: So does that mean
that like it might be 1.5, or
1.3, or 1.--
BORIS SMUS: Exactly.
PETE LEPAGE: It could be
anywhere in that number.
BORIS SMUS: Yeah.
I mean we're probably going to
start seeing greater than 2x
as well going forward from--
well, maybe not from Apple.
I can't speculate there.
But it's certainly likely to
increase up to the point where
you can't see any
pixels anymore.
PETE LEPAGE: That would
be really cool.
That would be really neat.
BORIS SMUS: We're getting
close already.
You have to look really
hard to find them.
So that's sort of the story.
Android solves the problem by
letting you provide like four
different images.
So you have a very small,
medium, biggish, and extra,
extra large--
PETE LEPAGE: Now this is if
you're doing an Android native
application.
So that doesn't really apply
for web developers.
BORIS SMUS: No.
I'm trying to set
the stage here.
And on the web, the whole
problem reduces
to CSS scaled pixels.
So the way that works is
essentially the spec provides
an angular size.
The spec defines pixels
to be an angular unit.
It's a little confusing.
But you should read
the article.
I think it explains
it pretty well.
The basic idea though is a
pixel is a certain angle.
So depending on how
close or how far--
PETE LEPAGE: Oh.
When I read it, I was trying to
figure out, OK, an angle to
me is sort of this way.
But it's more the angle
this way coming out of
the screen at you.
BORIS SMUS: No, it's your
viewing angle actually, not
the screen.
So if the screen is in front of
me, then I have a certain
viewing angle.
And what this means is basically
the pixels' physical
size depends on how far the
screen is from me, So this is
the spec definition.
PETE LEPAGE: Now, this gets kind
of confusing and a pain
for developers.
BORIS SMUS: Sort of.
I think in practice,
it's a lot simpler.
PETE LEPAGE: Good.
BORIS SMUS: So the way this
works, the specs sets this
angular pixel.
And then a browser vendor can
assign the device pixel ratio,
which scales virtual pixels
into this physical pixel.
So essentially, what device
pixel ratio does is it scales
every CSS pixel to the
physical size.
And at that point, you basically
don't even need to
know what the spec says.
PETE LEPAGE: I like that because
this is sounding more
complex than I think
it should be.
BORIS SMUS: Right.
But with device pixel ratio, you
kind of abstract yourself
from the gory details of the
spec, which I go into if
you're interested.
Take a look at the article.
There's even a little diagram
to illustrate that.
But yeah, basically, the
pixels are scaled.
But you still have
the problem of--
essentially, if you're scaling
pixels, then your images are
being scaled.
And if you scale images to be
large, then suddenly you have
really crappy-looking--
PETE LEPAGE: Lower quality.
BORIS SMUS: --lower
quality images.
So the question then is
how do you serve the
right size of image?
And there's many ways.
I mean, one solution is you
just serve high DPI images
everywhere.
PETE LEPAGE: And that's
fantastic for anybody who's on
a high-speed, dedicated internet
connection who
doesn't care about their
bandwidth, which is probably
not everybody.
In fact, I'd guarantee
it's not everybody.
BORIS SMUS: Especially on
Mobile, things are really--
well, you have slow speeds.
You have very high latency,
generally, from 3G
connections, even
4G connections.
Essentially, latency isn't
really changing, because it's
constrained by distance
from cell tower.
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
So the further I am from the
cell tower, the longer it's
going to take for the radio
signal to come.
So it doesn't matter how fast
I can get everything, it's
still going to take a little
bit of time for the--
BORIS SMUS: So there's all
these sort of different
constraints in mobile.
So anyway, there's multiple
solutions.
You can do this in JavaScript.
And there's a whole spreadsheet
that someone put
together of all the
JavaScript--
PETE LEPAGE: Libraries.
BORIS SMUS: --Image solutions,
OK high DPI image solutions.
And there's like at least 30.
So it's pretty impressive.
There's also CSS approaches.
So with CSS media queries, what
you can do now is you can
select the proper image.
Well, essentially what you
do is you set a media
query based on the--
PETE LEPAGE: It's the
device pixel.
BORIS SMUS: Device DPI.
PETE LEPAGE: Device
DPI or pixel--
BORIS SMUS: Device
pixel ratio.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
So like at the top, I'd say,
hey, here's my CSS, and I
specify media query in there.
And I said device pixel ratio
of between 1.0 and 1.5.
And I might do another one
for 1.5 to bigger.
And that would give
me the high ones.
BORIS SMUS: Exactly.
PETE LEPAGE: Now, that's only
going to do images if they're
in a background, for my style
sheet, or if they're maybe
specified as a background
on a div or
something like that, right?
BORIS SMUS: Exactly.
So with media queries, you're
constrained to CSS properties
and not content images.
So you can't set the image
source with a media query.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
So I can't use that for,
say, hey, I want to
put an image here.
And this is my image of
a newspaper article or
something like that.
BORIS SMUS: You sort of can.
I mean, you can just create a
div, set the background image,
and pretend it was
a content image.
And like you can even say--
PETE LEPAGE: Then I would have
to generate that CSS every
time, depending on if the
image is dynamic.
So I'm thinking like
a news website or
something like that.
If the image is dynamic, I'm
going to have to do that.
BORIS SMUS: You can still
do that with JavaScript.
It's not a problem.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh yeah,
that's a fair point.
That's a good point.
BORIS SMUS: I mean, you can
set the background images
dynamically.
Anyway, so there's
JavaScript, CSS.
You can do this on
a server as well.
So just using the user agent,
which is all we have on the
server, unfortunately, you
simply just serve the high DPI
image if necessary.
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
So you could say, oh, this
particular device, I know is a
high DPI device, so I want to
serve the high DPI image.
Now, that's going to
work great for a
known set of devices.
But like, say, for example, some
brand new company goes
and ships the new, coolest
tablet ever.
And it's got a device
pixel ratio of four.
On day one, I'm probably
screwed.
BORIS SMUS: Well, you're not
screwed in the sense of--
PETE LEPAGE: If I use the
server side, and I
don't know about it.
BORIS SMUS: Sure.
If you're using the server side
and doing like a robust
solution, you're probably using
a device database, like
[INAUDIBLE] or--
what's the other one--
Device Atlas, one of those.
So there, you would just
update your database.
And hopefully, they
would be able to--
PETE LEPAGE: They'll
provide that info.
BORIS SMUS: But you know, that's
sort of theoretical.
There's definitely drawbacks.
And you'll need a custom
server solution
to do this, et cetera.
So the real solution to this
problem is to use things that
are built into the browser.
PETE LEPAGE: That's pretty
much always a
safe thing to do.
BORIS SMUS: Because
there's drawbacks
to every other approach.
And of course, the drawback here
is it's not implemented
everywhere.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
These are specs that
are still sort of--
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
PETE LEPAGE: Would you call
them release candidate?
Or are we still sort of--
BORIS SMUS: It's hard to
speculate about that.
I mean, they're both specs that
are somewhat in progress.
But certainly, we will have some
image selection, image
set approach for both content
images, like setting image
source, and for background
images.
So the way with background
images right now,
it's with image set.
And I talk about it in some
detail in my article.
But essentially, what you're
saying is you specify multiple
images, and you say what
the [? x-ity ?]
is, like 1x, 1.5x, et cetera.
PETE LEPAGE: So the device
pixel ratio, you
say one point whatever.
BORIS SMUS: So you provide
multiple of these images.
And then the browser selects
which one to load for you.
PETE LEPAGE: So the browser is
smart enough to go, oh OK, we
want to grab this.
BORIS SMUS: And it's
more of a guide.
So one of the drawbacks with
CSS using media queries is
your device pixel ratio may be
two, but you may be on a very
slow link, for example.
Then you're downloading a huge
image on like your EDGE
connection, and that's a
bad user experience.
So if the browser can make
that call for you--
PETE LEPAGE: We definitely want
the browser to do that.
BORIS SMUS: We want
to do that.
So I think that's the main
benefit of building it
directly into the browser.
So it's image set for CSS.
PETE LEPAGE: So that's
image set.
So I would say image colon and
then like provide a set?
I guess it's in the article.
BORIS SMUS: It's
in the article.
But it's essentially a
custom CSS function.
with its own syntax,
et cetera.
And right now, it's in WebKit
only, so prefix with the dash
WebKit prefix.
And it's available in Safari
6 and Chrome, I think.
[INAUDIBLE]
the Canary.
PETE LEPAGE: So it's not
available, say, on Chrome for
Android yet?
BORIS SMUS: Not yet.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
But something that--
BORIS SMUS: But it will be.
PETE LEPAGE: --we hope to see
coming in the near future.
BORIS SMUS: And I believe
it may be--
well, it's likely to be in the
next versions of both Chrome
for Android and probably
Mobile Safari as well.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
So we should keep an
eye out for that.
Hopefully, it'll be in
the next version.
BORIS SMUS: And of course, for
content images, we have a
similar thing called
source set.
So you have image source, and
you have image source set.
PETE LEPAGE: So I'd say image
source, and then I;d provide
the normal one so that legacy
browers or normal browsers
will just pick that up.
But then I'd say source set--
BORIS SMUS: Source set.
Yeah.
PETE LEPAGE: --and that's still
an attribute within the
image element, right?
BORIS SMUS: Exactly.
So it's sort of a little more
complex than image set, the
CSS version.
And you can specify additional
things like width and height
of the view port.
So again, this gets a little
more complicated.
And in my personal opinion, both
image set and source set
should have the same syntax.
They currently don't.
The other thing to know is
a source set is it's not
available anywhere.
There's no implementation.
PETE LEPAGE: Ah.
All right.
So it's cool, but we
can't use it yet.
BORIS SMUS: It's cool, and we
can use it with a polyfill
that I wrote.
But it's not available
in any browser.
So I would say it's far less
mature than image set and
likely to change more as well.
PETE LEPAGE: So the
link to your
polyfill is in that article.
So if people, go have a look at
that article, they can get
that link, correct?
BORIS SMUS: Correct.
So anyway, take a look
at the article.
Try the polyfill.
Let me know what you think.
PETE LEPAGE: So what
would you say--
I want to go, I want to make
my website work best now.
What's the best thing I can
do to make sure that I'm
providing the best experience?
BORIS SMUS: The best thing you
can do now sort of depends on
what your target is, who your
clients are, et cetera.
If you're targeting legacy
browsers, you probably want to
use something less ambitious
than image set and source set,
because you're just going to
end up having to polyfill
everything right.
So if you're doing that, fall
back to JavaScript, see if
media queries are supported, do
something less ambitious.
However, if you're on
the bleeding edge--
PETE LEPAGE: If you want to be
sort of on the cutting edge--
BORIS SMUS: --you should
probably be using image set
and source set.
Definitely image set, maybe
not source set.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
All right.
Well, hopefully that's
a good intro to this.
This is something, I think,
it's a little bit
complex right now.
It's a little bit more fun than
it should be, and fun is
a subjective thing, but will
become easier in the future.
This is something that I think
a lot of browser vendors are
looking at and trying
to figure out.
Because we really want to make
sure that it's easy for you.
And as developers, it should
be mostly transparent.
It should be something that you
go, all right, here's my
image, and maybe I need
a high DPI or low.
Actually, you know one that you
didn't mention, I can't
remember if you mentioned
it in your
article, but image formats.
There are some image formats
that provides that.
But it doesn't stop downloading
once it hits the--
BORIS SMUS: Right.
So one of the things I
discussed, as you mentioned,
are the progressive
image formats.
So if you remember in the old
days when GIFs were very
popular on the internet,
you can see
this progressive loading.
So first, you get kind of a
pixelly thing and then it
would refine itself instead
of the cascade of loading.
So most image formats actually
have this ability.
And a lot of the time, if you
encode it that way, it's
actually smaller.
In some cases, it's larger.
So I talk about that.
But you might think that, hey,
you can just do this and then
cut off the connection once
you know that getting more
data isn't going to improve
the quality of the image.
The thing with that is,
especially on mobile, you
don't really want to
kill connections.
The reason you don't want to
kill connections is because
now you need to respawn
a new connection.
And that incurs latency
overhead, which can be like a
whole second in many cases.
So one workaround could be
to use HTTP Range, which
essentially says get me this
chunk in some image.
So what you might do is you
might get the head of an
image, see the size, estimate
how much data you need, get
the range, and then
you don't actually
have to kill the request.
But the trouble is nobody
supports Range
on the server basically.
So anyway, more details,
check out the article.
PETE LEPAGE: It's
a great article.
It's really worthwhile.
There's a lot of great images.
BORIS SMUS: Thanks Pete.
PETE LEPAGE: I liked it.
BORIS SMUS: Anyway, let's talk
about some debugging stuff.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
All right.
Well, I'm going to grab my
laptop here, because I want to
talk about some of the debugging
tools that Chrome
has to offer as you're building
websites and web
applications.
So I'm just going to
bring up Chrome.
And I want to show you a couple
of the emulation tools
that are available to you.
And then I'll jump into some
of the debugging tools.
So I've got Chrome up.
I'm running Chrome
Beta on this.
But in addition to Chrome Beta,
this is also available
on Chrome Stable, it's also
available on Chrome Dev, and
there's a couple other ones.
I'm going to take a sec here.
Apparently, we're getting
some flickers.
So let's try and see if I can
unflicker a little bit.
All right.
So do you want to talk about--
BORIS SMUS: Sure.
So basically, there's multiple
kinds of approaches you could
take to debugging.
The simplest probably, if you're
developing a mobile app
and don't really want to deal
with your Android device
plugged in via USB and doing a
remote debugging, the other
approach is to emulate some
mobile features that are
available in Chrome for Android
but do it directly on
your desktop Chrome.
So in the dev tools, as Pete
started saying, there's a
bunch of these pretty nifty
features that let you
essentially constrain your
Chrome browser in ways that
are similar to the constraints
that you'll
find on mobile devices.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
So we've got this up.
So I'm going to bring up
the Chrome dev tools.
So I just brought them up
on my new tab page.
But if you click--
BORIS SMUS: Maybe you could
bump the size up.
Command Plus.
PETE LEPAGE: Command Plus.
There we go.
Yeah.
So I clicked on the settings guy
here, and that brings up
my settings.
Now, things look a little bit
weird right now because I
bumped the size up.
But there's a couple of things
that pop up here that are
really interesting.
Let me come down a little
bit in size.
So the first one is Override
User Agent, Override Device
Metrics, and Emulate
Touch Events.
So by going and turning on the
Override User Agent, I can go
in, and I can choose from
different user agents.
So I can specify, hey, I want to
emulate a Galaxy Nexus, or
an iPhone, or an iPad.
So if I choose the emulate the
Galaxy Nexus, sure enough, it
goes and sets my user agent
string to be the right user
agent string.
But it also goes and turns on
this Override Device Metrics
and sets my screen resolution
for 720 by 1280.
So it actually says, hey,
this is what my
screen resolution is.
So now, if I go down here, and
I open up google.com, sure
enough, I get the experience
as I would see
it on a mobile device.
BORIS SMUS: So it's both the
user agent and the device size
constraints.
PETE LEPAGE: Exactly.
So as far as Google is
concerned, I'm reporting as
this device, and as well, I'm
also getting the right screen
resolution.
So I'm kind of faking
out this.
Now, there's a couple of things
that I do lose here
that we don't get.
One of things we talked
about earlier was the
device pixel ratio.
If there's any kind of device
pixel ratio that's beyond the
normal, I'm not going
to get that.
BORIS SMUS: That's actually
on the horizon.
So it may be coming soon,
definitely talked to some
people about it.
It seems like a very
useful feature.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
It's something we definitely
asked for, and we've gone in
and said, hey, we think this
is really important.
I had checked this morning to
see if it was in Canary or
Chromium, and it wasn't
there yet.
BORIS SMUS: Not yet.
PETE LEPAGE: So fingers crossed
that we'll get that
kind of soon.
Because that would
be really useful.
It's one of those things
that I think will help.
Now, one thing that sort of
caught me a couple of times, I
go to start using this, this
may catch you, so in this
particular environment, my
screen is set up for 1080
pixels high.
And you'll notice that when, I'm
just going to bring this
up again so that we
can see this--
that wasn't what I wanted.
Here we go.
There we go.
So I'm going to bring this up.
Notice my screen resolution
is set for 1280.
So it's a little bit bigger
than my screen.
So the browser creates that
space down below.
Now, what's happening, say,
for example, I want to see
this whole thing.
I want to get rid of this.
If I go close this right
now, I actually--
oh, it looks like
we fixed this.
No, we didn't.
BORIS SMUS: It reverted back.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
It reverted back.
So now, what's happened
is my screen size
goes back to normal.
BORIS SMUS: So you need to have
dev tools open for the
[? screen ?] size effect.
PETE LEPAGE: So this dev tools
need to stay open if you want
to do that.
Now, there's two things
you can do there.
You can just sort of go and
shrink these guys really,
really, really tiny.
Or the other one you can do is
just undock them and move them
sort of over here.
And that's probably the easier
thing to do, because now you
can actually go and--
BORIS SMUS: There's actually
a third thing
you can do in Canary.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
Let me bring up Canary.
I think I had some fun with
Canary this morning in that It
wouldn't bring up the--
yeah, it won't bring up my--
BORIS SMUS: Oh, don't
worry about that.
But if you click on that
thing for a while and
then go like that.
Boom.
Dock to right.
PETE LEPAGE: Nice.
BORIS SMUS: So that's a
pretty cool feature.
PETE LEPAGE: So that's something
we can probably
expect to see in a future
version of Chrome.
BORIS SMUS: Yeah.
I think it's probably
in Beta by now.
I'm not sure.
PETE LEPAGE: Well,
let's find out.
BORIS SMUS: Is this Beta?
PETE LEPAGE: This is Beta.
So it is not in Beta yet.
So maybe it's in Dev.
BORIS SMUS: Yeah, could be.
It'll trickle down eventually.
It's a very useful feature.
PETE LEPAGE: It really is.
It's one of those things to
be able to go and do this.
So not only do you get your user
agent override so that
you can go and specify, if you
do want to specify a specific
user agent, you can do that.
Because right now, they
only have Android 4.0.
And do you remember,
is this the Android
browser user agent?
Or is this the--
let's see--
BORIS SMUS: Good question.
I think it's the Android
browser user agent.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
That looks like the
Android browser.
BORIS SMUS: There's no Chrome
in that string.
I think there's an open request
to get Chrome user
agents in there, Chrome for
Android and Chrome for iOS,
but not quite yet.
PETE LEPAGE: It's
not there yet.
BORIS SMUS: Either way, as you
were saying, you can and paste
in anything you like.
You can even paste into
Googlebot if you want to see
how Googlebot [INAUDIBLE].
PETE LEPAGE: Oh yeah.
That's a good point too.
So if you want to go look up the
user agent strings, if you
just look up Chrome Mobile UA
string, just Google that,
you'll come across the
documentation.
BORIS SMUS: You should get
to the developer site.
PETE LEPAGE: So let me just
bring these guys up again.
So the other one that you can do
is emulate touch events so
that if I want to go and turn on
touch events, and I'll pop
over here and go back
to google.com--
helps if I spell it right.
You'd think I'd be
able to do that.
I can sort of simulate
the touch events.
Now, they're not true
touch events.
But they're plenty close.
BORIS SMUS: I think they're true
touch events, like you
get the same touch start, touch
move, and touch end as
you would in a normal event.
PETE LEPAGE: So good point.
BORIS SMUS: So a lot of sites
that are designed for mobile,
like this one, might not respond
to clicks directly,
because they assume that--
PETE LEPAGE: Oh yeah.
They're not expecting
a click event.
They're expecting only
the touch event.
BORIS SMUS: It might be that
there's a mobile user agent,
and they just say, OK,
there's only touches.
So it's useful in that case.
But of course, it's
not multi-touch.
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
So I can't go and do any
multi-touch kind of stuff
unfortunately.
All right.
So that's the emulation stuff
that you've got within Chrome.
The other one that's available
is Chrome remote debugging.
And with the Chrome remote
debugging, there's a video and
lots of good documentation
on that.
But on my phone, I'm just going
to go and open up Chrome
so that I've got something
that we can go
have a look at here.
Now, before you do this, you
need to have ADB installed.
Now, ADB is the Android
Debugger.
And it allows you to do
some port forwarding
and things like that.
Once you've got ADB installed,
which is not all that hard--
it's a pretty easy process
to step through--
you need to plug your phone
into your laptop via USB.
And you need to turn on two
things on your phone.
In the settings menu
for the phone, you
need to enable debugging.
So go into the debugging
settings, turn that on.
And then the second piece that
you need to do is within
Chrome, you need to turn on
the remote debugging.
So I've done that
on this device.
And now I need to start
the debugging stuff.
BORIS SMUS: Yeah.
So generally, the stuff on the
device persists, at least the
system-wide debugging does.
The Chrome one sometimes turns
off for some reason.
So you might have
to turn that on.
But there's a bit of like
one time setup.
Hopefully, you won't need
to do it all the time.
PETE LEPAGE: Once that setup's
done, it's pretty easy.
I've actually created a little
script to make my debugging a
little bit easier, because I
don't like to remember ADB
forward TCP colon 922--
It's just more than I
like to remember.
So I just got a little script
that I can do, clank, debug.
So that starts my
clank debugger.
BORIS SMUS: So what that
actually does is this Chrome
for Android runs a server,
basically.
And it runs the Chrome
dev tools protocol.
And what this does, it
sets up the port.
It opens the port here
to make that
connectable from your desktop.
PETE LEPAGE: So now, through
the USB, I've opened a TCP
port to the server on here.
BORIS SMUS: It's actually a
little more complicated.
You'll see.
Anyway, we should
open this up.
PETE LEPAGE: So now,
I've opened it up.
And sure enough, I see my list
of inspectable pages.
I can click on this.
BORIS SMUS: So you'll see it
actually went to a front end
that's on the web.
The URL here is chromedevtoolsfr
ontend.appspot.com.
So it actually serves the
front end from there and
points it to here.
So a bit of indirection.
PETE LEPAGE: We've got a little
bit of funky stuff.
BORIS SMUS: But it works
really well.
So it's awesome.
PETE LEPAGE: So now, as I start
looking at the content
that's on here, I can actually
start expanding these out and
seeing what's going on in
my particular page.
So I can expand this out, and
say, hey, there's divs.
There's an iframe.
And as I start expanding these
out, you can see that
different parts of the page
start to get highlighted.
BORIS SMUS: So you have full
control basically.
PETE LEPAGE: Exactly.
It's just like debugging
on my desktop.
Like if I'm debugging,
I can go in.
I could be like, oh, hey, I can
change everything live.
I've got all the same
capabilities that I would have
if I were debugging Chrome
on my desktop.
I can set CSS styles.
I can set attributes,
remove attributes.
I can add and remove elements,
all the stuff that I'm used to
being able to do.
In fact, I can even go in and
use some of the auditing and
profiling tools to be able to
understand exactly where
everything is.
BORIS SMUS: It's especially
important for mobile.
PETE LEPAGE: Exactly.
To understand how your network
requests are coming in, it's
actually something really
interesting.
One of the projects I was
working on, we found a bug
that only happened when you
are connected on 3G.
So we were testing this.
We were always on Wi-Fi,
because that's--
generally if you can go
on a fast connection.
We're great.
And we were like,
all right, yeah.
And a couple of hours before we
were supposed to ship this
thing, I was doing my last like
sanity checks and went,
oh crap, it doesn't work
with Wi-Fi turned off.
And so sure enough, it was just
this little thing where
something wasn't coming in quite
fast enough, and it was
just sitting there forever.
And so we made a couple
of minor corrections.
But it was one of
those things.
So being able to go in and see
the profiling tools, the
timeline for how requests get
made is a really useful tool
to be able to have.
BORIS SMUS: Right.
So actually, that will
be network, right?
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
Yeah.
There's network.
BORIS SMUS: Timeline is
also very useful.
PETE LEPAGE: So if I reload
this page, sure enough,
there's all the resources that
are getting loaded for this
particular image.
And I can see how
long this took.
So like the page DOM content
loaded was fired here
at this blue line.
And here at this red line,
the load event was fired.
BORIS SMUS: That's awesome.
Super useful.
PETE LEPAGE: Very useful.
BORIS SMUS: Yeah.
So this is running milestone
18 of Chrome.
And it's on par with m18.
But now Chrome has moved
a little forward.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
So I'm running Chrome Beta
on this machine.
And Chrome Beta is 21.
So Stable will be 20.
All right.
So with that, why don't me pop
over and take a couple of the
questions from the
moderator queue?
BORIS SMUS: Sounds good.
PETE LEPAGE: I'll grab
the first one.
So the first question-- let me
just reload this, make sure
we've got the latest stuff.
What's your opinion on using
mobile framework such as
jQuery Mobile?
BORIS SMUS: Good question.
PETE LEPAGE: It is
a good question.
So I think, my opinion, using
stuff like that has its place.
And I've used jQuery Mobile
for a couple projects.
I thought it was a neat sort
of place to start and
experiment with.
It doesn't necessarily work
for every single project.
And it does provide a few
headaches here and there, if
you want to do things that
jQuery Mobile doesn't support
or sort of falls outside
the box.
What's your view on it?
BORIS SMUS: I kind of agree.
I think it's great for sort of
these apps that are very
content-centric.
So you have like hierarchical
sets of views that are all
kind of similar and
maybe text heavy.
PETE LEPAGE: I want to
go look something up.
I want to flow through
something,
something like that.
BORIS SMUS: And you can break
out of the mold with plug-ins
that have a plug-in framework.
So if you want to do something
a little bit outside of that
framework, it's fine.
But if you're doing like a
complex app with its own kind
of UI, maybe there's some
drawing app or something where
it's a lot of interaction that's
not really common to
the sorts of apps that it's
designed for, I would say
don't use it and like look
to something else.
Maybe look to a framework like
Sencha or something like that.
Or roll your own.
Because ultimately, you might
need to go there.
PETE LEPAGE: Do you want to read
off the next question?
BORIS SMUS: OK, let's see.
Any way to launch Chrome
after clicking links
in any apps on iPad?
It launches Safari even
after updating Gmail?
Right.
So basically, you can--
as an iOS app developer, you
can write an app that will
check if Chrome is installed
and launch
Chrome instead of Safari.
That said, it's up to the app
developer and not the user.
So if I, the user, say if I
want Chrome to be launched
every time any link opens,
I'm out of luck.
iOS doesn't provide that
sort of flexibility.
So about Gmail specifically,
they have their own agendas.
PETE LEPAGE: They
may hopefully.
That's actually a good point.
We'll go send an email
to the Gmail team.
But I know that the Google+
team just updated their
Google+ app.
If Chrome is installed, it'll
open links in Chrome on iOS if
it's installed.
So it's going to be a matter
of getting developers to go
and start doing that.
If you have an app or use an
app, go ask your developer to
enable that feature.
That will be a really
nice thing to have.
BORIS SMUS: Yeah.
Totally.
All right.
Next question?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
Next question.
BORIS SMUS: All right.
So there's a question about
using a master key to secure
saved passwords in
Chrome for PC.
So I think this is something
about key chaining, probably--
PETE LEPAGE: What's the
specific question say?
BORIS SMUS: What about a master
key to secure the saved
passwords in Chrome for PC?
PETE LEPAGE: Huh.
So I would say maybe if--
I am not sure I quite understand
the question, but
if you can go provide a little
bit more detail in there,
we'll take a look at that this
afternoon and try and put an
answer in there if we
can understand that.
BORIS SMUS: There
was one more.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
One more question.
I think we'll take this as
our last question and
then wrap it up.
BORIS SMUS: So workarounds
to--
this is not really
Mobile-related, but I think we
can probably talk a
little bit about.
Workarounds to execute
dynamically generated scripts
in iframes in Manifest 2.
So this is an app or
extension question.
PETE LEPAGE: So I think with
that, the one piece that I
would say to go have a look at
is the sandboxed iframe stuff.
Because with sandbox iframes--
with Manifest version
2, they implement
Content Security Policy.
Content Security Policy is a
piece that helps to protect
you from cross-site scripting
and other security
vulnerabilities.
And it restricts some of the
things that can happen.
With a sandboxed iframe, you
can do a lot of not so safe
stuff, but it's sandboxed
and can't get outside
that sandbox generally.
BORIS SMUS: So you can do eval
in a sandboxed iframe?
PETE LEPAGE: You know, I can't
remember the exact list of
things, but I think you may
be able to do that.
So it's worth having a look
at the sandboxed iframe.
And the sandboxed iframe is
actually a larger piece that
doesn't just fit into Chrome
apps and extensions, but it's
something that's coming
to the web in general.
BORIS SMUS: Right.
And if you're doing it on the
web in general, you can also
set your own custom Content
Security Policy.
PETE LEPAGE: Absolutely.
And you can modify
that as well.
BORIS SMUS: So I guess Manifest
2 sort of suggests
that you're doing it in Chrome
apps or extensions.
PETE LEPAGE: Good point.
BORIS SMUS: All right.
I think that's all
the time we have.
So thanks guys for joining us.
PETE LEPAGE: Thank
you very much.
And we'll be doing these
more regularly.
We'd love to hear
your feedback.
Let us know either through
the comments or
anything like that.
So with that, thanks
very much.
And we'll chat soon.
Bye bye.